hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we're going to be breaking
down a deleted scene from spiderman no
way home which was shown in a
behind-the-scenes video so let's get
straight into it so in this clip you can
actually see a burglar running away from
a cop and then he is presumably stopped
by spider-man as he is webbed up into
the air and is swinging side to side now
this character was actually played by
tom holland's brother harry holland
which tom holland described in an
interview so in this scene tom said
harry also had a couple lines to do as
he was in side to side we don't actually
know what these lines are but at the
moment all the footage we have of the
scene is of him running away from the
cop being webbed up and swinging side to
side which there's actually alternative
footage of from an instagram story which
you can see playing in the background so
that's about it for this video guys a
very quick video but i just wanted to
break down this deleted scene for you
guys hopefully we'll actually get these
deleted scenes released at one point as
i would like to see them do you think
the scene should have stayed in the
movie or do you think it was a good
decision to remove it also don't forget
to like and subscribe and to turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching